madame la Première ministre nous
entamons l'examen de la loi contrôle de
l'immigration et renforcement de
l'intégration je veux dire ici que
lorsque l'on parle de migrant il s'agit
d'être humain un migrant c'est un homme
un migrant c'est une femme un migrant
c'est un enfant qu'être français s
connaître notre histoire que notre pays
s'est construit par vague d'immigration
successive mon grand-père Louis rebusi
était italien d'origine cette
particularité je partage avec Eric
sootti et Jordan Bardella notamment je
connais cette histoire le mépris les
rejets et la bêtise humaine un rapport
du préfet du Nord au début du siècle
dernier expliquait que les Italiens
vivaient toujours ensemble ne parlent
pas le français sentaiit mauvais et il
concluaient qu'ils étaient
inassimilables mon grand-père a combattu
à Verdin et deux de ses frères sont
morts pour la France être français c'est
défendre les valeurs de de la République
c'est faire vivre la sa devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité sur la loi
immigration elle doit nous permettre
d'être plus efficace et plus juste à
liyotte nous sommes pour le réalisme
nous ne voulons ni angélisme ni
extrémisme la question de l'aide
médicale d'État qui permet aux étrangers
en situation irrégulière de se soigner
sous certaines conditions doit être
étudié par ce prisme les sénateurs ont
voté sa suppression or en 2012 l'Espagne
avait pris la même décision avant de
revenir dessus car cela avait entraîné
une hausse des cûts et 15 % de la
mortalité des personnes concernées 10000
professionnels de santé nous alertent
revenir sur laame serait catastrophique
engorgerait les urgences or nous
connaissons déjà le triste état de nos
services de santé supprimer la me c'est
donc prendre un grand risque pour la
santé de tous nos compatriotes quelle
est la position précise de votre
gouvernement sur cette question elle est
importante
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président la
parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Bertrand Pancher
alors comme vous l'avez dit l'examen du
projet de loi immigration porté par le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald armanin a
commencé hier en commission ce projet de
loi répond à une préoccupation de nos
concitoyens et il vise à relever un
double défi et
plus efficacement ceux qui n'ont pas le
droit de rester en France et mieux
intégrer ceux que nous choisissons
d'accueillir monsieur le Président
Pancher je suis certaine que nous
pouvons nous retrouver autour de ces
objectifs avec les parlementaires de
votre groupe comme avec ceux d'autres
groupes de l'arc républicain vous l'avez
souligné lors de l'examen du texte au
Sénat l'ame a été supprimé au profit
d'une aide médicale d'urgence sur ce
sujet la position de mon gouvernement
est claire l'ame est un dispositif
nécessaire nécessaire parce qu'elle
répond à un impératif de santé publique
elle permet de soigner les personnes
malades présentes sur notre sol sans
passer nécessairement par les services
d'urgence elle permet de prendre en
charge rapidement des maladies et
d'éviter leur propagation comme les
hépatites le VIH ou les infections
respiratoires j'ajoute que l'ame est un
dispositif extrêmement contrôlé c'est
même celui dont le taux de contrôle est
le plus élevé de l'assurance maladie
alors monsieur le Président Panch une
réforme de l'Ame a déjà été menée en
2019 elle s'était faite logiquement dans
le cadre de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale comme vous avec mon
gouvernement je cherche toujours
l'efficacité de nos politiques publiques
et je suis ouverte à des évolutions de
laame mais pour y parvenir nous avons
besoin d'un diagnostic complet et
objectif c'est l'objet de la mission
confiée par les ministres Géral daranin
Aurélien Rousseau et agès firmain
lebaudau à Patrick stéphanini et à
claudvin les conclusions de cette
mission seront rendu d'ici quelques
jours elles seront naturellement rendu
publi avec les ministres nous
proposerons le cas échéant les
évolutions nécessaires dans le cadre
d'un texte adapté monsieur le président
Bertrand Pancher nous sommes déterminés
à apporter réponses justes et efficac au
français cela vaut sur laame comme sur
les autres sujets je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre